ام
[موسيقى]
براقش كلبه امتلكها قوم في بلاد العرب
تحرس بيوتهم والحقول واذا ما اقبل الليل
نام اهل القريه باطمئنان
ساهره ذات ليله ظلماء اهتمت الكلبه هجوم
جماعه من قطاع الطرق على القريه الامنه
ربحت حتى انقضت اهل القريه وفروا ب ذهبهم
وفضتهم الى كهوف مجاوره ومن اقف امامهم
تعد ولهم طول الطريق وصل اللصوص الى
القريه فلم يجدوا سكانها ولا ثرواتهم
عبثوا بالبيوت ثم هم وابن صراعه لكن براقش
الكلبه ربحت من داخل الكهف وتعقب اللصوص
الصوت ووصلوا الى مبتغاهم نهبوا المال
وعدم الرجال وقتلوا براقش وقيل يومها وعلى
نفسها جنت براقش
بينما الاصح ان يقال على قومها جنت براقش
الى العناوين
امريكي ينتصر لفلسطين وعربي يؤيد بناء
الهيكل
احتجاجات فرنسا في اعلام السيسي اخوانيه
من تصدقون المخابرات والكونغرس ميتران
الاعلام السعودي ما كروم بين يدي الامير
معتذرا
من هي ياله التي تعيد للبشير شبابه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا فوق سلطه الاحتلال والاستبداد وفوق
سلطه المنفعه الشخصيه تربع هذا الاسبوع
المراسل السابق لشبكه سي ان ان ميركل
الذي لا يرى فلسطين الاب خارطتها الكامله
من النهر الى البحر
فاصبح مراسلا سابقا مفصله من الشبكه دون
توضيح الاسباب
لكن مجموعات مواليه لاسرائيل شنت عليه
حمله شعبا بعد مغادرته بمواقفه فهل تسعى
مجموعات مؤيده ل فلسطين الى تعويضه بعض
عمل على الاقل بدءا شبكه الجزيره
هذا الاعلامي الفاضل متهم بمعاداه الساميه
لدينا ناشط سعودي متهم بمعاداه العروبه
وربما اكثر محمد سعود بل شغله من حضراتكم
يوجه من قلب الرياض رساله تهنئه الى
الاسرائيليين
بمناسبه عيد الحنكه الذي يدخل في صلب
العقيده اليهوديه
المتصله ببناء الهيكل
النور
وما تزال انها البلوي مجنونه في السعوديه
لانها زاهر ترفض التطبيع لكن مهلا هل ان
عواصم الخليج مستعده للاختراق الاسرائيلي
القادم وربما القائم راس السلطه هناك
بنيمين نتنياهو
وحرمه سار مطلوبان للاستجواب بتهم فساد
فهل تتسرب هذه الافكار الى صفوف المطبعين
لا توجد غير هذه الطريقه لمحاربه التطبيع
اخوفهم على عروشهم
والاسرائيلي ما لو ام ان تقول امهاتنا
يعني حتى لو وعدوكم بعدم التدخل بشؤون كم
عبر المتبعين سيتدخل هل يحققون مع هذا امر
تغربنا و لكن ان كنت محققون التحقيق مع
الجميع ما يبعث على الاطمئنان ان المحلل
السياسي البحريني عبد الله الجديد يؤكد
نتنياهو لن يضعنا في جيبه نحن اسرع اه اب
ل لكي يضعنا بنيامين نتنياهو في جيبه
الاعلى
ويضحك علينا للامانه الاستاذ جنيت في
العاده حريص على اختيار كلماته لكنه في
قصه الابل هذه لم يوفق برعايه الابل
والغنم ليست من قصه ولا مذمه بل هي شرف
ومكرمه كما عند البخاري من حديث ابي هريره
رضي الله عنه ان النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام قال ما من نبي الا رعى الغنم وزير
الامن الاسرائيلي السابق مش يعلون يحسم
المساله لا وجود لنزاع عربي اسرائيلي
فنحن في خندق واحد
اعتقد اليوم بانه لا وجود لنزاع عربي
اسرائيلي نحن في خندق واحد هذه قضيه مصالح
في الماضي كانت الايديولوجيا في العالم
العربي مجنده ضد اسرائيل الناصريه
والقوميه العربيه والبعثيه جميعها كانت ضد
اسرائيل اليوم الاسلام المتطرف يحاول
القيام بذلك وهذا يشمل القياده المصريه
والاردنيه ولها الى الحاكمه في السعوديه
يعالون تفضل اذن بجوله سياحيه ول تبدا من
القاهره وعمان واخبرنا بالانستغرام اذا
وجدت فيها من يبيع حصول اذا عرفوا انك
اسرائيلي اترك الحساب علينا حبيبي قرارات
الحكام الشيء وخيارات الشعوب شيء اخر
نشرت شبكه قدس فيديو قالت انه تم تصويره
في مصنع بمستوطنه بركان الاسرائيليه يظهر
وجود مواد كيماويه التجاريه تنتجها شركه
السعوديه ايرلندا الان على وشك اقرار
قانون يقاطع اه البضائع المنتجه في
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه وفي الاراضي
المحتله من المؤسف والمحزن تقدم اطراف
عربيه على مثل هذا التطبيع مع حكومه تقوم
بكل هذا الاطلاق
الشعب الفلسطيني
ولم يبقى ب عزام الاحمد ممثل حركه فتح الا
ان يستشهد بنصف بيت من شعر مظفر دواء وكما
قال ظفر النواب القدس عروس عروبتكم
القدس
هذا ا بذلك
[موسيقى]
انت ست الحكومه الفرنسيه غضب المحتجين ليس
باحراق اعتصاماتهم بارضهم واتهامهم
بالعماله بل بتعليق قرارها زياده الضرائب
على الوقود لكن اذا كانت فرنسا لا تعلم ف
اعلام السيسي يكشف عنه السترات الصفراء
اخوانيه الم تلاحظوا ان شعار رابعه اصفر
واسود وليس بعيدا على الاطلاق ان جماعه
الاخوان والتنظيم الدولي للارهاب التنظيم
الدولي او هذه الجماعه ضالع في
باريس باريس
هيد باريس نفس الفكره بالضبط الاخوان يعني
السيطرات الصفراء كانوا بانتظار مكرون في
الارجنتين موظفو وعمال المطار لكن بدون
احتجاجات عدوا سترات الصفراء تنتقل من
فرنسا الى بلجيكا فهل يتوحد اوروبا ربيع
على الطريقه العربيه ملعبه من قبل ستين
سبعين دوله يقولون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فرانس 24 شبكه تلفزيونيه رسميه مسموح فيها
انتقاد الحكومه على الهواء وهذه عينه من
النسخه العربيه
فازت بطله اوروبا في اب ضرائب وهذا امر
نشعر به انا وانت
رقما قياسيا في الضرائب المفروضه على
المواطنين على المستوى الاوروبي لكن هذه
الحريه لا تجعل دوله فرنسا افضل من
ديمقراطيه السياسي احنا نحن نحسب من فرنسا
معنى الكلمه على فكره
احسن من فرنسا ردا على سؤال لاحد
الاعلاميين عما ستكون عليه روسيا بعد
اعتزاله العمل السياسي طمان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الى انه باق باق
نجت بقره من الذبح في استراليا بسبب حجبها
الضخم فلا توجد اله ذبح وساعتها لذلك سيتم
الاحتفاظ بها ما بقيت على قيد الحياه
وهكذا فالبقره الكبيره تحلم ولا تذبح شيع
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جورج بوش الاب بما
تم الرسمي في الكونغرس واهتمت مواقع
اعلاميه امريكيه بحضور كلمته السائله التي
بدت عليها علامات التاثر وهناك من حرصه
على مواساتها في مدينه ليفربول ببريطانيا
عرض تمثال مصنوع من مائه الف سكين والحاد
مصادره ارتكبت بها جرائم الطعن على مدى
سنوات
استطيع ان اتخيل الان بماذا تفكر لكن ل
يعثروا على الجثه اولا والمسار لاحقا
انه التجسس عن حب وليس عن مصلحه والمفاجاه
ان هذا الحب السياسيه الاعمى من المتهم
عند القضاء الفرنسي بنوده هو لزعيم كوريا
الشماليه كيم جونغ انه مفتون بحكمته كنيدي
هو مؤلف كتاب حول كوريا الشماليه وكتب
مقالا تعده حول الدوله المعزوله وكان من
اشد المعجبين بسياسه رئيسها كيم جون اون
كيم جونغ اون الذي يفخر البعض من الصوره
الديكتاتوريه والحربيه لشخص اطلق مع نظيره
الجنوبي قطار السلام بين الكوريتين بعد
انقطاع استمر سبعين عاما فيما تتسابق
دولنا العربيه على قطع الطرقات فيما بينها
[موسيقى]
عرضنا الاسبوع الماضي بانتقاد تفصيلي
مقاطع لسوء استقبال ممثل الحوثيين المبعوث
الدولي لجهه التقاليد الدبلوماسيه نتابع
للتواصل الدبلوماسي بين الدول قواعد وايت
بروتوكول يبرا فيه الاوروبيون وتبرز
المدرستان الفرنسيه والبريطانيه
مساكين الفرنسيون والانجليز فالمدرسه
الحوثيه تتقدم للتسلح معايير جديده في
التقاليد الدبلوماسيه ممثل مليشيا
الحوثيين في اليمن استقبل المبعوث الاممي
مارتن
فاجلسه على يساره وليس بمحاذاته فيما ا
تضع الحوثي على مقعد رئيسي الحوثي احضر
معه سلاحه الكلاشينكوف ووضعه تحت المقعد
عسى ولعل
اما العصائر فتشرب مباشره من التنكر
العبوه الحوثي احاط مقعده بهاتفين وعربتي
محارم وسله نفايات حسابك في تويتر يسمي
نفسه من اليمن هنا القدس علق على حساب
البرنامج بالقول نحن لا نفهم بالاتجاه و
انتم لا تفهمون بالكرامه نتوقع مثل هذا
لكن الذي لم نتوقعه تغريدات ل مئات من
عناصر الميليشيات الالكترونيه السعوديه
تشتمون ليش قال لاننا ما نحنا الحوثيين
وهذه عينه بندر يقول من يشاهد هذا المقطع
الدرامي والتطبيل ي للحوثيين على لسان
اعلامي مرتزق يتضح معنى الخيانه القطريه
والتطبيع الفارسي الى اخره
وماذا اقول غير ما قاله الشاعر
اقول له عمرا فيسمعه سعدا واكتبه حمدا
وينطقه زيدا
طيب اليوم عرض خاص بمناسبه عيد الشموع في
كولومبيا سن تبني وجهه النظر الرسميه
السعوديه ونعرض معها روايات الاعلام
المغرب مع املنا بان فهم صح هذه نقطه
مصافحه حاره ميزت قمه الارجنتين بين
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان غاز خصوم
الامير فكيف لا اعرف ان بوتين كان متفقا
متلهفا لمصافحه بن سلمان الروسي متشفق
بوتين الرئيس الروسي بوتن متحف جدا للقاء
الامير رئيس وزراء كانت ان تريد ايضا كان
متفقا وربما متشقق للقاء الامين
تحدثت مباشره الى ولي العهد واطلعته على
مخاوفنا والحاجه الى اجابات من افضل حول
مقتل
خبر اخر وقفه الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانيا
الماكرو مع ولي العهد ترجم الاعلام المغرب
الاصوات الصادره عنها بانها توبيخ
للامير
بينما الحقيقه في الروايه الاخرى هي ان
مكروه كان يعتبر من سموه في البدايه حرفوا
مرتزقه الجزيره على انه اه احمد عن السياق
عندما بهرت الصوره والصوت بحكم واضح تحدثت
بان الرئيس الامريكي يعتبر من الامير محمد
بن سلمان
اكثر من ذلك يقولون مكروه قال له انا بدي
مكرونه سلمان اتيتك تائبا
فاغفر مكان وبين يديك اقول الان عذرا عذرا
عذرا كمان ولكني اعتقد ان ما قاله يا سمو
الامير انا مع الاسف وقع
من اعلام مضلل ومجلس وصدقنا ما سمعنا وانا
بين
لكن اعلام فرنسا الرسمي المغرب يقول غير
ذلك
انما كره مره الرسائل بصوره صار ميل ولي
العهد فيما يتعلق بقضيه اغتيال الصحفي
جمال خاشقجي حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حتى
اعلام روسيا طلع مجرد مجرد فقال الرئيس
الفرنسي مكروه يتحدث بحده خلال حوار مثير
مع محمد بن سلمان في قمه العشرين البي بي
سي قمه الغربيه اذا استمعت
يعبر عن اه قلقه من شيئا يقوله انا قلت
انت لا تستمع عليه في حين ان ابن سلمان
قائلا انه سوف استمع اليك من دائره اعلام
ولي العهد هناك من وقع في الفخ وصدق
الروايه الاعلاميه العالميه الموثقه
لموقعه التوبيخ المزعومه ونصح مكروه بان
يسطر على السيطرات الصفراء لك السيد ماركو
يلتفت هذه الدقائق الى ما يجري التشاديه
وبغيره الف متظاهر وهناك مع الاسف على
توجيهات من الرئيس مايكرون الى تسليم
معدات الشرطه الفرنسيه بكل الاحوال بين هي
اوروبا وليد المعلم حذفها من الخارطه مجمل
الدول الاوروبيه ليس الاخير في هذا المجال
ودعني اقول
الايتام
ان هناك اوروبا على الخارطه ليس وكاله
رويترز اليست مغرضه تقول ان السيد الامير
تعرض للتهميش في قمه العشرين التهم يسال
وهي كادت ان تصبح قمه العشرين ثلاثين تغرد
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
للتهميش خلال التقاط الصوره الجماعيه
الرسميه لزعماء العالم وكبار الشخصيات في
قمه مجموعه العشرين
وغادر ولي العهد الذي يعتبر الحاكم الفعلي
للسعوديه المنصه بسرعه دون ان يصافح او
يتحدث مع اي من الزعماء غير وحسب كل ذلك
غيره وحسن من من ظل الخليج والشرق الاوسط
يعطي دروس في كل
كان يذهب اليه اليوم شفنا حضور الشاب يفكر
هذه الكريمه لرجل مثل مانديلا قبل عمر عمر
طويل في عالم السياسه الباحث المخضرم في
معهد الشرق الاوسط طوماس لبنان يفتري على
السعوديه العظمى ويصفها بالضعيفه السعوديه
ضعيفه انت تتحدث عن السعوديه هنا السعوديه
ليس تركيا او حتى مصر السعوديه او القوات
المسلحه السعوديه
دعنا نقول لديها سجل غير حافل والسعوديون
واضح ان هم غير مستعدين لارسال قوات بريه
الى هناك لهذا يرسلون مرتزقه تبدو
المخابرات الامريكيه ومراكز نفوذ متنوعه
في الكونغرس مصره على اعتبار الامير محمد
متورطا في قتل خاص احاطات مطالعات رسميه
التسريبات وكلها تصب في هذا الاتجاه
لكن ماذا يضير الامير اذا رئيس امريكي
يقول عنه بريء ربما يغير تنظر ايه بوتين
سيئه واذا غير بوتين كيم جونغ اون سيثبت
البراءه اعرب عضوان جمهوريان رئيسيان من
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي عن يقين هما
بتورط ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان في
قتل الصحفي السعودي جمال خاشقجي
وبعد حضورهما احاطه مديره وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه جون قال السيناتور
بوب انه ليس لديه اي شك في ان الامير محمد
بن سلمان هو من امر بقتل يخشى فيما وصف
السيناتور لن تجدهم ولي العهد بالمجنون
الخطر والهدام يا شباب ليش ما منحط علنا
براسنا ونتمنى جميعا روايه الصحفي احمد جر
الله بان قطر وتركيا وايران هم المتهمون
في قضيه خاصه ويا دار ما دخلك شر ويقول يا
ما دخلت من شهر وطبعا المتهم فيها تركيا
وقطر وايران القضيه الخارجيه ايضا لن عرض
فيديوهات الاعلام المغرب الذي يتحدث عن
الرفض الشعبي لزياره ولي العهد للجزائر
وموريتانيا بلس نتبنى الروايه الرؤيه
والاحتفالات الشعبيه في هذه الدول
استقبالا للامير ذكرتنا بجولات جمال عبد
الناصر العربيه
ولو عرض اعلام الرؤيه فيديوهات ل عرضناها
في جوله الامير مظاهرات احتفالات شعبيه
وهذه الصفه لم تظهر ايضا الزعماء ولم تعد
اثر معهوده في جانب هناك كاريزما الشخصيه
والقيمه هي العامره كما توقعنا سابقا فان
هوليود لم تترك جريمه قتل خاصه دون توثيق
فقد قال الممثل الامريكي الشهير شو في
محيط القنصليه السعوديه باسطنبول في اطار
تحضيراته لفيلم حول الجريمه تشمل لقاءات
مع مسؤولين اتراك ومع خطيبه خاص فماذا
تقترحون عنوانا للفيلم ولماذا تسبق
هوليوود السينما العربيه وهي الاقدر على
الاحساس بالقصه
[موسيقى]
من هي ياله التي تعيد للرئيس السوداني عمر
البشير شبابه
ولم اكن يالا
نيالا نيالا المدينه السودانيه الجميله في
جنوبي دارفور رئيس الوزراء العراقي السابق
حيدر العبادي حازم قوي شجاع بشهادته شخصيه
لكن الاصلاح لم يترك له صاحبه الاصلاحات
في الاصلاحات للاصلاحات وحتى على مستوى
الطرق
مفترق الطرق ان تخسر كل الاصدقاء مواطن
اردني يبتكر طريقه ابداعيه
لاجبار رئيس الحكومه على الوقوف واخذ
شكواه فما هي
[موسيقى]
المالكي
يرفض ان يطرح الاسئله عليه حول حزبه في
لال غويني يغادر استوديو على الهواء ثم
يندم سيعود بين يعني اصحاب خيار الموالاه
خيار المعارضه لم يحدث هذا الانقسام على
مستوى حزبكم في ذلك انتقل هذا الانقسام
الجانب التنظيمي ان هناك المجهول التنظيم
موجوده نعم قتل فيها للنقاش
المستجدات السياسيه
شكرا جزيلا
لك كما شاهدتم نحن مضطرون لانهاء هذه
الحلقه بعد ما انسحب اليس لك الحق اسمح
لا يمكنك ان تمنع الممارسه
طيب وليس لك اي حق فان تمنعنا من الحصه او
من مواصله عملنا احتفال ديني خاص في دمشق
ل زوجات مسؤولين وسيدات اعمال بمشهديه
جديده ونادره
[موسيقى]
الله
الله الله الله
[موسيقى]
اخيرا وفي القاهره القضاه والسياسيون
والاعلاميون منشغلون ب فستان الفنانه
رانيا يوسف الذي وصف بال فاضح علما ان كل
المعترضين ايدوا من قبل ما هو افضل القتلى
المتظاهرين موضوع مشهور جدا مع مشهوره في
الجرائد المصريه والجرايد العالميه
يا سيدتي
عن الحدود المسؤوليه لكن من اللي مسؤول
الهجوم
المسيئه البذيئه اللي ظهرت في ال اه في ال
في هذا المهرجان من المسؤول انه يصور
القاعده في الارض عشان يدين في زاويه
معينه عشان يطلع من حرام او الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
كان متزوجا بامراه الاولى من كبيره في
السن
الثانيه صغيره
الابيض في زوجها الى ما تيسر منه
حتى لا يقول الناس انها متزوجه من رجل
ابيها
كانت الشعر الاسود في زوجها
مثلها
وبعد مده من الزمن الرجل في المراه
لا ابيض ولا اسود
بين حانه ومانه ضاعت لحانا
الى اللقاء
ام
[موسيقى]